Within 3JS, you can create a set of particles by using the particle system
object. The code here shows one way to make some particles. For the material,
we load a disc texture that is transparent around the edges. Using this texture
and particle basic material says to make a billboard type of object that points
towards the camera. In other words, we want to see this sprite texture always
facing towards us. Setting size attenuation to false means we that want each
particle to have a constant size on the screen. Setting the size to 35 means
that we want the particle to be 35 pixels wide. The next bit is to make the
particle system object itself by using a set of points in the particle
material. By setting sort particles to true, this means we want the particles
in the system to be sorted with respect to the camera's view. This is
important, as otherwise blending will not occur properly. When you have objects
with transparency, you need to draw them in a back to front order so that they
combine correctly. The geometry object you pass into a particle system is a
list of vertices. In this example, 8,000 particles are being created and added
to the scene. I randomly generate these vertices within a box going from
negative 1,000 to 1,000 and x, y, and z. And check that each is inside a sphere
of radius 1,000. If not I ask for another random point. There are more
efficiently is to generate to random points in a sphere, but this is quick to
remember in code. Try the demo out, if you dolly out far enough, you'll see the
sphere formed.